hello and welcome to this video playing
typhoon 45 and um it's player a queen
pawn opening looks a bit like were
transposing to a Queen's Gambit if he
goes is six No
okay the the whole move on that black
went for is really odd
okay now how do you how do you not lose
now
[Music]
it's that that's not so obvious really
93 because he would have to play some c6
to continue the game and not resign
immediately and it could be useful to
not have a knight on c3 in this in this
case
yeah I think it's just this is going to
be useful the thing is now let's think
about this even Bishop takes is going to
be very strong Bishop takes Bishop takes
Knight takes and having double attacking
the Queen and the bishop
Knight takes Bishop takes Bishop takes
rook c8 and it's also very good and that
looks like like game over almost
I'm just returning now to take on d7
winning everything
one idea of king in two is that instead
after 93 he might just take on c3 and
make sure that before Bishop is simply
gone and now it's still a liability due
to the fork on c6 or Queen a form I
think this is why King it to was a good
idea
not much not much to do him
Quincy eight maybe yeah so yeah that's
let's have a look them okay this is um a
real sideline nothing too dangerous
black should play 94 as the main move
okay Knight b7 is of course no mistake
III I'm slightly skeptical about b6 this
is just a bit of a strange move order to
play b6 so early and weaken the light
squares you can easily imagine this this
this and then b6 like in the terekhova
okay b6 I have c4 and now it's it's a
bit of a problem I mean you want to play
six but then you're sitting in in this
thing and it's it's going to be
difficult it's just difficult
you played Bishop b7 instantly instead
of thinking and now I don't know looks
slow it looks lost
c6 maybe instead of the check to
continue of course I can simply take a
pawn and I can't and I'm better but this
is at least continuing a little bit yeah
but we gain something like this it's
just extremely good for white probably
just 93 it's the center pawn for nothing
yeah now if I play this he can actually
take yeah this is and okay white is
better here but it continues the game
continues and if instead I'm playing the
King King f1 seems to be stronger even
this is now more convincing I'm a little
bit surprised Quincy Quincy 8a thought
Queen a4 would be strong then a but then
just a six I see
sorry hey why is six ship takes Knight
takes a days Queen Queen g4 at the end
or what
see 595 24 is this why King f1 is better
that's maybe that is probably the reason
why here King f1 is better
why doesn't that win ce6 Wow
I mean it it wins technically speaking
up when this should win but it's not
like I'm the media piece up or anything
yeah that's an awful position okay yeah
okay plate c6 and after Bishop takes
resigned there's just nothing left there
you can do something like this but
position like that is not going to last
the d5 pawn it's also just dropping now
you go back here and then Knight c3
Queen b3 building the pawn basically and
with it the game black's pawn structure
is non-existent it is it is rather odd
to play this so early
yeah okay there are openings like the
Queen's Indian but there you don't have
d5 played I mean you play a six b6 and
be flexible with the pawn here this is
not a good good timing I believe okay
guys thanks for watching